Multipliquemos 4 x 2,012; de hecho, hagámoslo un
poco más sencillo: multipliquemos 4 x 201 sólo
para simplificar un poco las cosas, entonces,
4 x 201. Como hemos visto en videos anteriores,
me gusta escribir el número más grande en la
parte superior; ésta es sólo una de las muchas
formas de abordar un cálculo como éste. Escribiré
el 201 y luego escribiré el 4 justo debajo de él,
y lo escribiré justo debajo de la posición de
las unidades, y entonces tengo 201 x 4. Ahora,
este proceso es esencialmente el mismo que usamos
cuando multiplicamos un dígito por dos dígitos:
primero multiplicamos 4 x 1, bueno, 4 x 1 sabemos
que es igual a 4, así que colocamos un 4 aquí
en la posición de las unidades; luego podemos
multiplicar este 4 por el dígito que tenemos en la
posición de las decenas, en este caso tenemos un
0 en la posición de las decenas, entonces 4 x 0,
bueno, eso es sólo 0, 4 x 0 es 0, ponemos el 0
en la posición de las decenas, aquí; y luego,
por último, tenemos 4 por este 2 justo aquí, así
que 4 x 2 = 8 y ponemos el 8 aquí y obtenemos
nuestra respuesta: 804. Ahora, ¿por qué funcionó
esto? Bueno, recuerda que cuando multiplicamos 4
x 1 eso fue literalmente 4, y tenemos ese 4 aquí
mismo; cuando multiplicamos 4 x 0 estas son 0
decenas, así que ponemos 0 decenas aquí; y cuando
multiplicamos 4 x 2 este 2 en realidad es 200,
pues está en la posición de las centenas, entonces
4 x 200 es 800, así que lo que esencialmente
estamos haciendo al escribirlo en la posición
correcta es pensar que 4 x 201 es lo mismo que 4 x
200, que es 800 + 4 x 0 decenas, que es 0 decenas
más 4 x 1, que es 4, entonces 800 + 0 + 4 es 804.